Alors, bonjour à tous, tout d'abord, madame la vice-présidente conseil scientifique
représentant le président, vice-président au sévu président adjoint, également j'ai
vu la vice-présidente déléguée à la cohésion territoriale quelque part, voilà, donc la
convie de l'UFR à l'origine de ce projet et moi-même, directeur de cette faculté,
vous souhaitons tout d'abord la bienvenue à ces rencontres de la recherche en lettres,
langues et sciences humaines. Nous sommes très heureux de constater que vous avez répondu
assez nombreux à notre invitation. Alors ces rencontres trouvent leur origine dans la volonté
que nous avons aujourd'hui à l'université de mettre en avant toujours plus la recherche
en lien fort avec notre mission de formation professionnelle. Cette volonté se cristallise
plus particulièrement aujourd'hui à l'université d'Orléans autour des instituts thématiques
pluridisciplinaires qui sont donc des regroupements de laboratoires dont le but est de travailler
à une plus forte imbrication de la recherche et de nos formations disciplinaires. Nos laboratoires
sont une grande richesse, travaillent sur des thématiques très variées et nous pensons
qu'il est dommage de ne pas étendre le cercle des privilégiés qui ont accès à tout ce
savoir. Notre objectif par ces rencontres c'est de proposer à un public élargi ce qui d'habitude
reste plutôt réservé aux personnes directement concernées, c'est-à-dire les chercheurs et les
étudiants de la spécialité. C'est ainsi que nous avons dans cet amphi des enseignants, des enseignants,
chercheurs, des étudiants, des différentes composantes de notre université mais aussi des
personnels administratifs et un public non universitaire. Donc merci encore de notre présence
et sans plus attendre donc je vais laisser la place à nos intervenants. Alors donc peut-être une
petite précision avant, l'après-midi va durer un certain temps puisque nous avons prévu cinq
interventions. Vous avez la possibilité bien sûr d'aller prendre un café, des petits gâteaux pour
vous restaurer et puis vous sortir un petit peu. Voilà entre deux conférences on va dire. On ne
fera pas vraiment de pause complète qui risque de faire dériver le temps. Voilà mais n'hésitez pas
à aller vous servir quelque chose, c'est juste au dessus, vous avez sans doute vu déjà,
vous avez repéré l'endroit. Voilà alors nous allons commencer avec l'Iramat. Voilà le principe
c'est donc que chacun de nos laboratoires va présenter, l'un de ses enseignants chercheurs
va présenter une recherche, quelque chose qu'elle ait à travailler donc il va nous faire
profiter. Alors l'Iramat, premier de nos laboratoires par ordre de présentation, là simplement bien
sûr, institut de recherche sur les archéomatériaux, matériaux anciens, donc un laboratoire qui fait
partie de l'institut thématique, pur et disciplinaire, humanité, culture et société qui est donc
attaché à notre collégium UFR LLSH. Alors quelques mots rapides de présentation de ce
labo avant de laisser la place à notre collègue. L'institut de recherche sur les archéomatériaux
est une unité mixte de recherche du CNRS et de l'université d'Orléans. Donc l'Iramat est
constitué de trois composantes, le centre Ernest Babelon de l'université d'Orléans,
le laboratoire de paléométallurgie et culture de l'université technologique de Belfort-Mont-Béliard
et le centre de recherche sur la physique appliquée à l'archéologie de Bordeaux III.
Lors de sa création en 1980, le centre Ernest Babelon avait une mission de recherche
pluridisciplinaire appliquée à la numismatique. Depuis, les travaux du laboratoire se sont étendus
à d'autres matériaux anciens, notamment aux verres synthétiques et naturels, aux pigments,
ces colorants et aux métaux utilisés dans la construction médiévale. Pour chacun de ces
axes de recherche, la vocation du laboratoire est double, développer des techniques non
destructives de caractérisation des archéomatériaux et appliquer ces méthodes pour répondre à des
problématiques historiques et archéologiques. Bernard Grattus, directeur du centre, va nous
parler de Bernardo Perotto, verrier italien immigré d'Alta, un orléané au cœur de sa ville et de son temps.